few stars in hollywood have been as
consistently great as denzel washington
the star of fences man on fire training
day and many more has always been an
electrifying presence on screen no
matter what the film
still as with any actor washington is at
his best when he's working alongside a
great cast
and visionary director 2004's political
conspiracy thriller the manchurian
candidate
starring denzel washington leave
schreiber and meryl streep has
all that and more the film is one of the
best psychological thrillers of all time
and it's just started streaming on
netflix the manchurian candidate is a
remake of a 1962 film of the same name
starring frank sinatra lawrence harvey
and angela lansbury which tells the
story of a soldier who is brainwashed by
chinese communists into becoming an
unwitting assassin
under the control of his diabolical
mother to further her power grabbing
goals
the original film was a massive success
when it was first released earning two
academy award nominations for best
supporting actress and best editing
it even received entry into the united
states national film registry in 1994
for being culturally significant
as you might expect that's a lot to live
up to when making a remake
but the 2004 version more than lives up
to the original by remixing the plot to
better reflect modern day concerns
sounds great that's what they wanted me
the 2004 version updates the time period
from the korean war to the war on terror
era
and the enemy from communists to a
shadowy multinational private equity
firm
with extensive political connections
called manchurian global
denzel washington stars as major bennett
marco a gulf war veteran who served with
sergeant raymond shaw
during a mission marco commanded shaw
single-handedly shot down a helicopter
full of enemy combatants
and saved all but two men in the unit he
received the medal of honor for his
heroism
about a decade later shaw is a
congressman being pushed into a vice
presidential run by his domineering
mother hawkish virginia senator eleanor
prentice shaw while marco is seemingly
suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorder in the form of nightmares about
the mission
nightmares that seem like they might
actually be buried memories in which
they commit
unspeakable acts against their fellow
soldiers marco begins to investigate
what really happened in the desert
and discovers that he and shaw have mind
control implants in their bodies
manchurian global is behind it and
they're conspiring alongside elements in
the government and the military to put
shaw their puppet in the oval office
the manchurian candidate was directed by
jonathan demi the versatile filmmaker
best known for the silence of the lambs
the movie reunited demi and denzel
washington who previously worked
together on the oscar-winning 1993 film
philadelphia and it's clear that their
creative partnership wasn't affected
during their time apart
the screenplay was written by daniel
pine and dean georgiaras
if the latter name sounds familiar to
you it may be because he wrote the
screenplay for the jason statham vehicle
the meg
though there's plenty of danger in the
manchurian candidate don't expect to see
any sharks
tina sinatra daughter of frank sinatra
served as one of the film's producers
her father owned the rights to the
manchurian candidate and she inherited
the rights after his death in 1998.
the cast of the manchurian candidate is
stacked with star power
in addition to two of hollywood's
biggest and best movie stars
the movie features early appearances
from actors who went on to become stars
including jeffrey wright
anthony mackie and leave schreiber's
brother pablo as members of marco and
shaw's unit
the conjuring star vera farmiga is on
hand as jocelyn jordan shaw's
ex-girlfriend and the daughter of
eleanor shaw's political nemesis
liberal senator tom jordan the
manchurian candidate
received positive reviews from critics
with an 80 certified fresh rating on
rotten tomatoes
but wasn't a box office success and
failed to generate much awards interest
it's one of meryl streep's rare
performances for which she was not
nominated for an oscar even though she
definitely could have been
she gives a terrifying performance as a
politician poisoned by her addiction to
power
it's a sneaky good film that has aged
very well
as the themes of corporate control of
government have only become more
prescient in the years since
if you're in the mood to watch a high
quality psychological political
conspiracy thriller on netflix check out
the manchurian candidate as soon as
possible
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one